Film Courage: When did you
begin studying Netflix TV shows?
Script Doctor, Writing Coach, and Author Daniel
Calvisi: A few years ago definitely when I was
coming out developing my book on TV story Maps
TV drama the structure of the 1-hour television
pilot where I broke down the structure of one
hour pilots from a lot of different networks
and streamers and stuff and I definitely wanted
to have some Netflix shows in there and in that
first book I broke down house of cards which was
like the seminal big that was their first big show
that they produced and distributed so that was
a big benchmark for them and now I mean they've
had hundreds of shows since then of course but
but yeah it's fascinating and and writers always
ask me about that and they're like Netflix has
a thousand shows how can I get mine in there you
know which is a normal question you know but it is
extremely competitive and the thing is everybody
wants to get on Netflix even the established
filmmakers and established TV people and for
a while I don't know if they're still doing it
Netflix was overpaying the market for everybody
they were paying anyone more than other companies
were giving them it's actually kind of in their in
their company rules is if you're an employee of
Netflix and you can prove that someone who does
your same job at another company gets more
money than you they will raise your salary
up to that level at least that's the way they
started Reed Hastings put in that rule when they
first started but content-wise I mean they're a
huge studio they're a huge factory they do every
genre imaginable so it's an exciting place their
financials are crazy everybody's kind of like we
don't know how they fund so much stuff billions
and billions of dollars of content but somehow
they do it and so they're a big dog definitely
what if you you learned about the structure of
Netflix TV shows well they distinguish themselves
from definitely the major networks the broadcast
networks in that they target audiences and topics
more succinctly you know they're focused more on
a niche that's kind of first off you know your
broadcast networks like ABC, NBC, CBS and even
a lot of your basic cable channels they're going
for a broad audience I mean it's right in there in
the title they want basically everyone they want
every generation of the family to watch their show
so they're not that risky they're not that edgy
they're not cutting edge with style and tone and
film making but Netflix decided they were going
to be edgy and be more adult and more mature and
I mean in some cases just more R-rated and they
came out with House of Cards and it was more
like a movie it looked cinematic and it had nudity
and bad language and violence and it was heavily
serialized so I think they came out and they
wanted to distinguish themselves differently from
other broadcast networks at the time there weren't
that many streamers at the time now there are of
course but I think the number one thing that
they do is they're targeting niches in a global
audience so they know for example that in Brazil
Brazil loves cop shows or something so they're
targeting they want to find a cop show that maybe
has a a female detective and some other element
that they know is big in Brazil because they have
all these analytics so they develop that that
little niche show they go out to creatives and say
do you have anything for this audience and they're
targeting it specifically for that audience and
they definitely want a global audience because
because they want to sell subscriptions to their
service all over the world so those are a few of
the ways that they distinguish themselves and
there are some they don't necessarily use a
different act structure like a one hour drama on
Netflix uses the basic same teaser plus 4X teaser
plus 5x that other streamers and other networks
use for drama you know that I've broken down in my
book same with half an hour although half an hour
shows now they either call them 30- minute dramas
or dramedies they are more experimental some of
them are only 21 minutes some of them are over
30 minutes and there's really kind of no rules
really with those the majority do a cold open plus
three a but there is a lot of experimentation
which is exciting is there anything different
you will find with the characters of a Netflix TV
show that maybe other streamers don't have other
networks don't have I mean I would say probably
they're more edgy and dark a lot of the Netflix
material is dark even if it's entertaining and
even if it's targeted a younger audience you know
a show like Wednesday is darker than something
that's on like the CW channel you know a lot of
their high school shows Sabrina and the Teenage
Witch or other ones that I don't even know about
they're more edgy they're more mature and maybe
that's why they're successful is they're not
dumbing it down for kids they're not thinking oh
only kids are watching this so I'm going to make
this material less complicated or serious or edgy
you know they definitely have that thing where
they're not afraid to go dark what is one of your
favorite Netflix pilots so definitely stranger
things it's one of their most popular shows ever
huge audience and they put a lot of money into it
and they really market it because they know people
love it all around the world and it has a really
great pilot it has a really compelling crazy
opening where there's like a monster and so you
know I don't you don't see the monster I think but
you see its effects and stuff so you know you're
in this fantasy monster type of story where kind
of anything goes then you meet these kids and you
feel kind of the 80s Spielberg-ian type of family
nostalgia feeling kind of reminds you of like
Goonies or ET you know so they have that nostalgia
element that's the style they even show in their
in the pitch deck that they used which you can
find online they have stills from a lot of like
70s and 80s movies like ET and Close Encounters
of Third Kind and so they were definitely going
for that right off the bat but they have parallel
stories so they have the kids who are looking for
their friend who disappeared and then they have
11 the girl with the powers who's escaped from the
laboratory so those are parallel stories until
the very end when they meet and that's kind of
the cliffhanger like what's going to happen now
that they've met you know and will the boys know
that she has some kind of special powers and I
don't know if she maybe she doesn't even show
her special powers in the pilot I don't quite
remember but you know that something is amazing
with her she escaped from this secret Institute
so it has a really good ending you also bring in
adult characters Winona Ryder and the sheriff so
you have a good cast of characters different ages
different generations different tones to their
dialogue and it's a lot of fun yeah that's what
I was wondering is forgive me I don't know that
much about the show but that because there's
multi-generations and it has this nostalgia
element to it is that why it's had such a broad
appeal I think it I think it was a big reason it
broke out to begin with and the same with Cobra
Kai which is also a Netflix show you know people
of my age remember seeing the Karate Kid when we
were kids in the 80s you know and then kids today
will follow the younger kids in the show and they
like all the action and kicking and fights and
everything like that so yeah I think nostalgia
is a huge thing you definitely see that a lot with
shows on the air on all different networks you're
also seeing now movies that are about pop culture
trends like Barbie and like there's a movie about
the Beanie Babies you know and so people are
like oh I remember when I played with Barbie
or GI Joe I remember when I had a beanie baby
so that can be a huge thing even if you don't
have ownership of an IP kind of the general niche
or milieu that you are recalling it could still
have an nostalgic element you know let's say you
are writing something about an 80s rock band and
it's not specifically about you know Foreigner or
Def Leppard or Guns N' Roses but you kind of you
fictionalize we know that's kind of the world that
it is right well that's nostalgia people remember
hearing those songs on the radio so that could be
a good little window into the world that you could
bring in and nostalgia could help find an audience
for that yeah and I don't know if this is true
for other generations but it seems like younger
people now they like music from a few generations
ago because the people there's the debate when
was the best film and music well it was you know
whatever and it's not current and so some of
that is like you know I don't know if that's
true for other generations that they liked maybe
20 years prior content but yeah I think you know
I think about that a lot I'm actually writing a
pilot I have a pilot that's set in the hair metal
era in 1991 in LA and so I think about nostalgia
a lot and I think about older trends when I was
a kid we romanticized the 60s right I remember
my older brother even saying I wish I wish I was
born 10 years earlier so I could have been like
a teenager in the 60s I could have seen the doors
and Le Zeppelin and The Who and all this stuff and
that was the music he listened to he didn't listen
to that much modern music even though there
was great stuff happening at that time but so
we romanticized the 60s My Generation now I think
they're Roman they definitely romanticized the 80s
but now they're getting to the '90s and it's an
era that they were they were maybe really little
kids or they weren't even born yet and so they're
having their own ideas about it and they're seeing
kind of elevated you know examples of it in film
and TV you know that maybe weren't quite accurate
to the time but they're being made into kind of
caricatures and stuff and the music and the movies
they're discovering for the first time you know
you have a like call it needle drops now so it
shows like Euphoria and stranger things they're
actually writing about what songs they have in
each episode and some of them break out you know
what are the keys to making audiences binge watch
a Netflix series well Netflix from the get-go
was heavily serialized so they are not afraid to
do a lot of plotting they're not afraid to have
cliffhangers but they're not too reliant on big
cliffhangers because they know you're just going
to go to the next episode so it's not like you're
going to be waiting for a week you know but they
one thing they do is they don't bother to recap
the previous episode because you're binging and
they know you just watched it I have seen a few
shows lately on other other streaming services
like Max and Hulu and stuff and they do it not
just the previously on but they'll kind of back
up the story in the next episode they'll start
with like a minute or so showing the end of the
previous episode and I'm like why are you doing
that because we're binging it you know this is a
streaming service so that's one thing they don't
worry about but I think they use they go for high
concepts you know they get they go for ideas that
are pretty crazy and edgy and they like I said
they target areas of the world and markets you
know very niche oriented targeting they use their
analysis to know what audiences are interested in
so maybe that's the the thing is they know
if they're giving an audience something that
they know they want in Sri Lanka or whatever
they know they're going to binge it you know
I don't know does that touch on that yeah but
we had Nielsen ratings and so it's interesting
how somehow this seems like they they really have
the viewer dialed in more so than yeah they have
a lot more analytics than they did back in the
Nielsen days and also they're thinking about the
whole world you know before it was North America
it was you know friends is going to attract 18
million people on a Thursday night and the main
demographic is 18 to 35 you know for example and
maybe more women watch it than men maybe it's
like 60 40% or something like that but now they
know like in Indonesia these are the genres that
they watch in this region and this is however many
minutes they watch before they tune out and go
go somewhere else now they know what audiences
are watching in other countries down to the region
and they know the gender and the ethnicity and the
age and where they live and they have all these
analytics for what topics and what genres they
watch and they know how long of the episode they
watch before they stop and tune out they know if
they come back to it to finish the episode or they
know if they never come back to it and then what
do they go to next so maybe they're just maybe
they're just sampling that comedy but they bailed
out on that comedy two minutes in decided they
didn't like it and they went to extraction the
movie with Chris Hemsworth so now they're like
oh okay they're more interested in action movies
and they watched all of extraction and then they
watched Wednesday [Addams] so they just they have
so much data that it's just a lot more targeted
these days are there any don'ts when it comes
to writing a series for Netflix I would say just
try to not make it feel like a broadcast series
probably avoid procedurals I would say procedurals
are you know the case of the week type of shows
they're mostly on broadcast networks there are
a few on streamers like Poker Face I guess is a
pretty big hit and that's kind of a Columbo type
of mystery thing where there's a different story
every week a different case every week but Netflix
isn't really doing those so you probably want to
avoid procedurals and it probably does need to
be more edgy or dark or high concept than your
genre audience normally would be on a broadcast
network so a cop show on ABC is probably too broad
and too safe for Netflix they want something more
edgy they want more of a cultural element maybe a
setting that we haven't seen before so really
drill down on something specific you know be
specific okay so maybe then like an informant
and he's not normally part of the force but
they're going to pay him to infiltrate this world
because they know that person knew that world or
something and so yeah maybe yeah maybe like Naros
was a big hit for them there had probably compare
like narcos versus Miami Vice you know true I'm
sure Narcos is a lot more intense and there's
going to be more violence and adult situations
and it's just going to kind of be more mature it's
going to have a bigger budget it's going to look
more cinematic than you know a cop show on ABC.